we've already got plans for further
measures to protect airports against
drones we have as you say already
legislated there is a long prison
sentence for people who do this
there was an exclusion zone around
airports because I bear in mind this was
a criminal offense this wasn't somebody
who was conforming to the law this is
somebody who is deliberately trying to
disrupt an airport and whatever laws we
pass you can't prevent someone actually
breaking the law so we've got to
actually have proper measures in place
to deal with that eventualities as well
yes we're almost certainly gonna need to
toughen the laws but actually we need to
prevent this happening when people just
decide to wantedly break the law and
we've already put in place plans for a
registration system but of course again
it just it's fine to have systems that
work for those people who are using
drones responsibly or even irresponsibly
what we it's much more difficult to
legislate against is wanton criminal
behavior of this kind and this is
something that's not being experienced
anywhere in the world with no one
anywhere in the world has experienced an
incident like this before I hope that
nobody else does
but we have got to move very quickly
this is it's not a terror instant in the
conventional sense but it is a
disruption incident of a kind that we
have not experienced in this country
before other countries haven't
experienced and we're now going to make
sure we got all the measures in place
that we possibly can to prevent this
from happening